les semaines au bon jour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
tout d'abord que doit-on retenir de ce
premier round des négociations sur ce
plan de relance estimé à 750 milliards
d'euros alors je vois deux choses
importantes a souligné d'abord c'est la
remise en place du couple franco
allemand
c'est très important parce que rien ne
peut se faire en europe
sans une cohésion entre l'allemagne la
france la deuxième chose je trouve très
désagréable que l'on parle des pays
frites frugaux dit frigo en termes
péjoratifs
j'ai même noté cette notion de pays
arabes et je trouve ça tout à fait mal
approprié pourquoi parce que a priori
comme ça de première vue on ne voit pas
pourquoi le contribuable ou l'épargnant
du nord ce devrait payer devrait se
sacrifier pour venir au secours de pays
plus les cia nous fait même ce qu'on
appelle les pays du club med veut dire
de venir au secours de pays qui n'ont
pas toujours fait ce qu'il fallait pour
équilibrer leur finale tandis jetons
justifier la réticence de ces pays dits
fraude irada le chemin est encore long
pour arriver à un accord selon à charles
michel président du conseil européen
accor est d'ailleurs espéré fin juillet
concrètement quels sont les convergences
et les divergences qui existent
actuellement entre les 27
un malaise mais convergence va bien il
s'agit de de soutenir la relance de
soutenir la reprise de l'économie en
europe mais vous savoir par quels moyens
on peut pas faire n'importe quel
investissement
n'importe quel
annuler n'importe que tête il faut il
faudrait peut être beaucoup plus précis
donc en ce plan de relance
mais j'ajoute ceci quand même qui équipe
qui me rappelle des notions très
ancienne en économie il ya eu un
économiste en nous mêmes ce qui
s'appelait fait réaliste et qui ne
supportait pas c'était très
protectionniste et qui ne supportaient
pas l'indépendance de pays bas il disait
c'est comme si les français avaient
admis que tout l'hinterland autour de
marseille soit indépendant dont il
considérait que l'indépendance des pays
bas n'avaient pas lieu d'être ce que
c'était le débouché naturel de
l'allemagne des autres pays donc j'ai
entendu dans la bouche d'un d'un leader
écologiste les pays bas profitent
profitent de de l'europe parce que ils
ont le pas d'internât met donc en
quelque sorte
l'isolant la prospérité déborde dépens
de l'europe mais pas de l'europe du sud
notamment ont dit la même chose
d'ailleurs d annoncer que il profite de
l'europe plus que ce qu'il devrait donc
je trouve ça je trouve que c'est cette
espèce de construction d'un état fédéral
européen au forceps de mauvaise augure
est jeune et je n'attends pas de bonnes
nouvelles de ce côté là justement est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'il ya des pays qui
vont sortir grand gagnant de ce plan
historique selon vous non non tout le
monde est perdant
on est on est devant une crise très
grave mais il s'agit de trouver les
bonnes ne les peurs des provinces c'est
pour ça que encore une fois je me
félicite du rapprochement franco
allemand
mais pour faire 2-2 de vraies réformes
de comprendre le bonne mesure donc pas
pour distribuer l'argent des autres ces
cinq je trouve
on est on est on est le moteur est là
mais il faut l'orienter vers d'autres
mesures que cette ce projet fédéral et
on est là je tout aussi dangereux de
vouloir aux forceps installer une
fédération européenne sur l'exemple
américain on a parlé du moment à métal
parce que c'est en 1705 en double et les
états unis mais également fondé leurs
fédérations ne sont pas en europe après
un état fédéral et cette histoire de
d'endettement commun c'est le le début
de fédéralisme
je trouve inapproprié dans ce moment de
crise merci beaucoup
philippe simonnot d'avoir réagi avec
nous un ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste et auteur des nouvelles
leçons d'économie contemporaine aux
éditions gallimard
merci beaucoup